- [Voiceover] Hello, grammarians!
Welcome to the present tense,
or that which is happening right now.
The present tense is how we talk about
things that are happening
in the present moment.
Like, "I eat a donut."
If I say it that way, it means
it's happening right now in the present
as opposed to happening
later, in the future,
or before now, in the past.
The present tense is
what's happening right now.
If you can just imagine,
just put the words "right now" at the end
of anything that takes
place in the present.
"I eat a donut right now."
"Louise doesn't want
a catapult right now."
"The water is super cold right now."
"Bertie is singing in
the shower right now."
All of these sentences are taking place
in what we call the present.
There are a couple of ways
to form the present tense,
and I demonstrated two of them here.
So we can say "eat" or "doesn't" or "is".
We can also say "is singing".
So when you generally have something
that has "is" and "ing" in it,
means it's happening right now.
It's happening in the present tense.
So yeah, those are two of
the ways to form the present.
If the verb is kind of unadorned,
if it's kind of plain, "I eat a donut.",
not "I was eating a donut."
or "I ate a donut."
or "I will eat a donut."
if it's just kind of on its own like this,
it's probably gonna be
in the present tense.
Likewise, if you see the
word "is" and then "ing",
that also means it's in the present tense.
That's what you gotta know
about the present tense.
It's happening now.
You can learn anything.
David, out.